let me just bring you some breaking news
live here on Sky News in the last matter
of seconds I can tell you that the 58
year old man Peter Murrell who was
arrested as a suspect earlier on today
in connection with ongoing investigation
into funding and finances of the
Scottish national party the occupant of
this property I can tell you that he has
been released without charge pending
further investigation this statement
just in from police Scotland in the last
few seconds the man was questioned they
say bye detectives after he was arrested
here at 7 45 a.m this morning he was
released from custody three minutes
before 7 pm tonight they say that
officers carried out searches at a
number of addresses as part of this
investigation and they say a report will
be sent to the crown office and the
procurator fiscal they say they are
unable to comment further breaking news
Peter model has been released without
charge pending further inquiries news
just in here on Sky News this has been
the focus of this major police
investigation throughout the course of
today police officers coming and going
in huge numbers examining the garage of
Nicholas sturgeon and Peter model and
questioning exactly what has been inside
that property this is an investigation
that has centered around SMP finances
SMP fundraising over the course of the
last number of years 600 thousand pounds
was raised by the SMP by its members for
the reason of a second Independence
referendum that has formed part we
understand of this inquiry but breaking
news in the last few minutes Peter
Morrow that 58 year old man who has
spent almost 12 hours in police custody
facing a number of questions by the
detectives has been released without
charge
okay Connor and what exactly we heard
from Nicholas sturgeon spokesperson
earlier what did she have to say about
this
well yeah this has been uh rude
awakening for Nicholas sturgeon herself
who has issued a statement in the last
hour or so she says it would not be
appropriate to comment on a live police
investigation Nicholas sturgeon had no
prior knowledge of police Scotland's
actions or intentions and it continues
Miss sturgeon will fully cooperate with
police Scotland if required however at
this time no such request has been made
but it is of course the overriding
statement that has just been released
from police Scotland in the last few
minutes the 58 year old man who was
arrested as a suspect this morning has
been under questioning for 12 hours
Peter model has been released without
charge pending further inquiries okay
Connor just talk to us a bit about what
this means for the smp's future
well in the words of the new first
minister of Scotland Hamza Yusuf who was
questioned as well today about this he
said he recognized this was a difficult
day for the sap let's remember Peter
Morrow
who has been released without charge
tonight was at the helm as the chief
executive of the Scottish national party
the biggest political party here in
Scotland since 1999 more than two
decades in charge of that party he
resigned a number of weeks ago uh mired
in controversy over dwindling membership
numbers and newspaper had contacted the
smp's headquarters asking about a
suggestion that the SMP had lost around
30 000 members in the last 18 months or
so that was flatly denied by the party
initially and it later became apparent
that newspaper report was indeed true
and there was an accusation that Peter
muddle had tried to obstruct the truth
in some way coming out around those
numbers he resigned very quickly and
within days of course we already knew
that Nicholas sturgeon his wife was
leaving the highest office in Scotland
after three thousand days in charge
she has said all along that she would
not comment on what was a police live
matter and that changed within the last
hour or so with that updated statement
saying she had no idea of police
Scotland's intentions today and that
will be an interesting move forward as
we discover exactly what Peter Morrow
may or may not say now he is a man who's
walked free after questioning from
detectives throughout the course of
today his house the home that they share
here on the outskirts of Glasgow has
been at the center of a huge police
investigation a crime scene tent has
been erected usually that is reserved
for major police investigations and in
the last half an hour or so a van a
white van that was under that police
tent throughout the course of today
drove away and within that where we
understand a number of items what were
those items the back Garden off this
property has been under scrutiny has
been scared by those detectives today we
noticed a number of garden appliances
being removed things were being
photographed there were laptops being
shown by those detectives that we could
see from afar
uh so what will the conclusions of that
be all we know is that Peter Morrow has
been released without charge tonight